- I'm not risking knocking
it in to a (bleep) ocean.
- If you do not choose one,
both of them will fall.
- [Eric] No.
Hey mom.
- [Mom] Yeah.
- [Eric] Okay, I need help.
- So I've been seeing a lot of these,
don't push the wrong mystery
box into the water videos.
- Matt is in one of these boxes,
and he has no idea what you guys chose.
I put out a pull on Instagram,
and you guys decided which box
I should push into the water.
- I thought it would be interesting
if we raised the stakes.
So I decided I'd use Eric.
Rather than put Eric in a box.
I decided I would put one of Eric's
most prized possessions in the box.
I going to enlist the help of Ade.
We are both going to go out on
a boat with these two boxes.
One has Eric's Boosted board.
The other one is just filled with weights.
Eric will have to allow
his Instagram followers
to choose which box we
knock into the water.
I know I might seem like just
a mean spirited (bleep) hole,
but Eric pranks us all the time.
- Good morning guys.
I'm wearing a tank top
in the office right now,
because I'm going on a boat today.
They want me to help shoot.
I don't know what they want from me,
but I get to go on a boat.
So, I'm gonna go.
Let's go.
We're going on a boat baby!
(dramatic music)
You brought me here to be the GoPro guy?
And why is it...
Why are both of you guys
filming here right now?
You guys just seem like creepy
porn directors right now.
What are we gonna do on this boat?
What's the video?
What are you guys gonna do to me?
I get it.
I already know it's a prank.
- Have you ever seen that show Dexter?
- That show Dexter?
No, please don't murder me.
I don't want to get murdered.
Am I allowed to go to the front?
(dramatic music)
- You help me just set...
- [Eric] What's in the box?
- Alright, okay.
So, I thought it would be interesting
to do a video with you and
your Instagram followers.
Where you take photos
of these mystery boxes,
and you allow them to pick
which box they put in the water.
- That's it?
This whole setup was
for mystery box video?
Throwing something into the water?
- Yeah, let's do it.
- Now I get to plug my Insta?
- You get to put your
Instagram on in here.
- Amazing.
Alright, what's up guys.
I'm in the middle...
I don't know where in the water.
On a boat.
Two producers of BuzzFeed want
you guys to decide which box to push in.
Box A
or box B?
Which one?
I don't...
I have nothing else.
That's it?
What is in the boxes?
Oh, it's a mystery box.
- It's a mystery box, yeah.
In one of these boxes...
It's just random junk.
- Okay.
- Nothing, nothing important.
In a different box is your Boosted board.
So we took your Boosted board and
put it in one of these two boxes.
- No, stop, dude, no.
- No, no, no.
- I'm not, no...
Dude I'm not.
Dude I got a Boosted board
for 13 hundred dollars.
I'm not risking knocking
it in to a (bleep) ocean.
- This is the bay.
- Okay, what?
That doesn't matter.
I'm not, I'm not knocking
in my Boosted board.
You're telling me one of these
boxes has my (bleep) Booster board.
- One of these boxes...
- When did you get my
Booster board out of the...
- This morning.
Alright, hold on I'm not gonna...
I'm not gonna...
- Hold it, hold it.
- I'm not gonna knock
either one of these in.
These are the rules.
Ready?
- We fake it.
I'll do it if we fake it.
- Hold on, hold on.
Let me just give you the rules.
I'm gonna allow you to push in the mystery
box that your followers choose.
- They don't know...
- Hold on, hold on!
- Which one has the Booster board.
How does that?
- If you do not choose one.
Both of them will fall.
- No, that's so mean bro.
I just drove.
I drove two hours for you to take
the one thing I (bleep) care
about and throw in the ocean.
- The bay.
- No, shut the (bleep) up!
No way!
Okay, no.
No way.
- These videos get 5 to
10 million views each,
and then they follow the users account.
Those are Instagram
followers that you could get,
but you won't get them if
we don't make this video.
- Dude, this is the most weird
situation I've ever been.
Should I make a viral video,
and potentially lose a
13 hundred dollar board?
- Disagree with me if this is wrong.
- Okay.
- Followers equals money.
What if you get more followers
than this board is worth?
You're just throwing that away.
- Can I call my manager real quick?
Ask them what I should do.
- He's gonna call his mom.
- Hey, mom.
- [Mom] Yeah.
Okay, I need help.
They want me to do a mystery box video.
One of the boxes has
my Booster board in it,
and the other has a bunch of junk.
I don't know which is which,
and I have to pick, I have
to push one into the water.
- [Mom] No! I don't throw
money into the water.
- Like let's say I get like 20
thousand followers from that video.
- [Mom] Yeah?
- Is it worth it?
- [Mom] I don't know baby.
You make a choice.
You're an adult.
- Fine, okay I'm an adult.
I'll make a choice.
Thank you mom.
- [Mom] Love you, bye.
- Let's do it.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, (bleep) it.
- You're sure?
- Yeah whatever, it's gonna do well.
My theory is that if I push it in...
I don't think you guys will
let me push in the board.
Like I think if they pick the board,
you guys won't let it happened.
I'm shaking.
Do you see my finger?
52% said B and 48% said A.
I just push it in now?
Does the audience know which
one is the Booster board?
- Uh, I don't think so.
I honestly...
I don't even know...
(dramatic music)
- [Eric] Okay, so what was it?
We don't know?
Guys, where the (bleep) is the board?
I'm scared of the ocean!
- The bay.
- I can't even go down.
I can't go (bleep)...
Please, God dang.
Stop recording and help me get my board.
I'm not going until we get my board.
I'm not...
(boat starts)
Are you guys leaving me in the water?
What the (bleep)?
Guys, alright!
Okay, no it's not!
There might be fish!
Guys, what the (bleep)!
Oh my...
Come back!
Guys!
- Okay, so I wanted to address a few
other things that you might be thinking.
One, we didn't litter.
I went back and I retrieved the box.
Two the reason we never see
any of Eric's GoPro footage
is because Eric dropped
it in the bay and it sank.
- Oh my GoPro!
- So maybe we did litter,
but not on purpose.
And three, I wouldn't let Eric knock
his Boosted Board into the water.
In fact, his Boosted board
never left the office.
- I (bleep) told you.
You weren't gonna...
Dude.
- Are there any hard feelings about this?
- No, honestly.
Like as weird as it sounds.
I mean you guys like really...
It was really mean,
but I feel like that makes us
like really good friends now huh.
Like we're on another level of friendship.
Cause like my friends are
always really mean to me.
- [Christian] I don't think
that's what friendship is.
- [Eric] No it is, because
I'm gonna prank you guys back.
I better get a (bleep) load
of followers from this.
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new channel.
And now your part.
- [Both] Subscribe here.
- That was my part.